Facebook calls it Libra Facebook
recently proposed the digital currency
that would make it as easy to send money
around the world as it is to send a
photo and Libra is promising stability
because Libra would be backed by a
basket of major currencies users would
be protected from inflation in any one
country seems reasonable to me
but government officials were not happy
they summoned Mark Zuckerberg to
Washington I actually don't know if
Libra is gonna work but I believe that
it's important to try new things with
politicians threatening all kinds of
regulation Libra backers got scared
high-profile backers have recently
dropped out of Libra Visa Mastercard
stripe and eBay all quitting the
Association
why are politicians so opposed because
they threatened by it because this is
going to be competition for the US
dollar tech reporter naomi brock well
the government doesn't like this
competition but even if libras crushed
saz Brockwell other digital currencies
like Bitcoin can't be stopped
you want to send money to Russia to a
family member it's gonna be sensitive on
to send money to a relief effort in
Venezuela it's gonna be censored you
want to use Bitcoin for that your money
will get through that's an incredibly
powerful tool that gives people back the
freedom to spend their money where they
want to spend it bitcoins are generated
all over the internet by anybody is the
first currency we've ever seen that is
decentralized I can't show exactly and
that's why it's still around because
they haven't been able to have these
hearings they haven't been able to call
on the CEO of Bitcoin and say you'd
better cease and desist there's no
server to unplug there is no company to
shut down those CEOs or throw in jail so
it persists that's really exciting
digital currencies live on thousands of
individuals computers so no government
can stop them by pressuring any one
company Bitcoin a virtual currency when
Bitcoin started it was worth virtually
nothing but then it caught on
you've seen Bitcoin gained 40 percent
two years ago the price of one Bitcoin
reached almost twenty thousand dollars
then it crashed to three thousand today
the price is about nine thousand that
volatility deters many people from using
Bitcoin as money but for those of us who
don't trust governments it is the only
suitable money for free people still
there are playing
of skeptics I think it's more of a
gigantic classic pump and dump scheme
investor Peter Schiff there's nothing to
give Bitcoin value it does have values
it's a way to send the transaction
around the world where nobody can
interfere with it well first of all a
lot of people are gonna be interfering
that's there's a lot of regulation
that's now gonna come down hard on using
Bitcoin on anybody who trans accident
what government can't stop but they
can't even stop the obviously illegal
stuff on the dark web well but they
could stop it in the you know the normal
market they can get banks and financial
institutions and make it very difficult
Schiff also says Bitcoin isn't that
useful most people don't actually buy
things with Bitcoin people are buying
things with Bitcoin now I buy things on
overstock.com other people are looking
to escape China's currency controls it's
useful I just don't think it's gonna
work oh there's always valuable if you
don't own gold yet you should buy it
it's not that Schiff trust that
politicians will keep the dollar stable
he thinks people should buy gold gold
has worked for thousands of years
bitcoins only been around for 10 Gold
has actual value there's a huge industry
that needs gold jewelry then you have it
in consumer electronics and aerospace
and medicine
I bought gold I've bought gold coins but
then I've got to store them somewhere
and put them in a safe deposit box their
pain in the neck you're exaggerating how
much of a pain it is I mean first of all
gold doesn't take up a lot of room you
can store millions of dollars worth of
gold which is more than most people are
gonna buy in a shoe box my Bitcoin
investments done a lot better than my
gold investment well if you got in early
I mean that's you could say that about a
lot of bubbles until they pop so I'm a
fool because I bought Bitcoin no you you
know you're a fool because you're not
selling your Bitcoin I don't presume to
know which way prices will move but I do
know it's good to have alternatives to
these the value of these is only backed
by politicians promises and I sure won't
trust those and even if these things do
remain valuable I don't trust that
politicians won't someday tell me you're
not allowed to use your dollars for
things we don't like the US government
has put increasing
pressure on companies to stop working
with WikiLeaks the government decided
that they didn't want WikiLeaks to
receive donations funding to the website
is becoming increasingly difficult we've
seen a monopoly on the money supply for
a very long time and finally consumers
have a choice you can send Bitcoin
peer-to-peer to someone of the other
side of the world almost instantly at
very low cost and it can't be censored
that's incredibly powerful